et notre invité est resté tout au long
du journal jacques higelin ne va pas
quitter malgré cette déprime de malgré
cette déprime les primes de quoi de
l'actualité non ça ouais ouais ouais
ouais
oui c'est pas c'est pas très gai quoi
alors on vous invitez parce que c'est
notre manière à nous de fêter l'année
rimbaud c'est comme ça des baladins
comme vous qui disparaissent le temps de
décrire un poème puis qui reviennent
avec un nouvel album pour lui un album
de chansons plouay oui je sais que je
vais avec de la musique et des paroles
et des mots
alors justement je voudrais que on
regarde une image volée c'est une image
volée lors d'une soirée entre amis ou
jacques higelin chanter
qu'on cesse je me plante toujours au
piano un sacré j'ai dit ma psy gonzesses
ça ma petite fille c'était calme a pas
ma petite fiche pas encore grand père
mais ma fille coiffée boutique qui
s'appelle un izia ça veut dire quoi
bonjour d'ailleurs mon amour parce
qu'ils regardent et elle elle ce mec se
plaque contre l'écran il voit pas encore
le à lakanal un an et un mois et alors
vous avez écrit tout s'échange manche
le jour de sa naissance ah non non non
non non cette chanson-là we7 la musique
est le début ce qui est dit doit être
fait ce qui est fait est écrit c'est
comme ça c'est la vie
alors il y avait après j'ai mis 6 mois
ou sept mois etc sur le reste alors il
ya tous vos objets dans cet album de
chansons il ya cet hymne à l'amour à
votre petite fille puis a pris une
chanson qui s'appelle illicites
ouais hein ou l'interdît vous excite way
paris c'est votre chanson oui il n'ya
que l'interdît que je ne demande plus
que pour plus que ça c'est on trouve pas
si le csa rappelle mort aux al quoi mais
qui passe les gens ont dix mille fois
plus dans la vie et c'est vous qui êtes
un peu nous fait jeter vous faites un
non sec mais c'est fini maintenant on
peut dire oui vous êtes livre on l'est
on est aussi alors vous êtes resté
toujours très singulier j'ai dit tout à
l'heure des primes au moment où tout le
monde a un petit peu le blues
vous vous offrez une série de chansons
très gai on les a entendus elles sont
pas forcément des mais bon joyeuse
heureuse
voilà web bien voilà pourquoi parce que
je trouvais que c'était trop la merde je
veux dire c'est pas que je veux pas en
parler du tout mais je trouve que tout
le monde en parle quoi et quand ça
arrive à des points de pression comme ça
c'est bien aussi d'ouvrir une fenêtre
dire au monde on d'une bouffée d'air
quoi parce qu'on va pas sortir de tous
les problèmes uniquement à coups de com
je vois à coups de crs et à coup de
à coups de l'affrontement il faut un
changement spirituel aussi il faut que
les gens s'ouvrent un peu on va toujours
bien et égoïste et c'est peut-être la
raison pour laquelle on se trouve dans
des impasses la pollution le reste des
difficultés mais ya pas que ça et puis
les artistes ils sont là aussi pour
vouloir mettre pour que les gens
prennent bouffée d'air quand sinon on va
tous crever en plus on prouvera
tristement mais j'ai pas trop envie moi
pour ma petite fille en plus aussi
l'album là vous voulez ça vous ennuie la
voilà mais justement j'ai pu laisser
conclure ce journal c'est lé mot de la
fin le jacques merlin de terminer devant
déterminer dans quel genre bah oui
disney à votre fille à varisia d'amour
et on est embarqué spectateurs